it caused Northern Ireland's government
to collapse and the EU to start legal
proceedings against the UK but we now
have a new deal with Brussels branded
The Windsor framework here's what you
need to know on why we're talking about
brexit again
[Music]
I believe the Windsor framework marks a
turning point for the people of Northern
Ireland so this is all about the part of
the brexit deal that relates to Northern
Ireland basically when Boris Johnson
signed it just over two years ago it
left Northern Ireland with a lot closer
ties to the European Union because it's
the only part of the UK that has a land
border with the EU both sides agreed
there couldn't be any checks or
buildings or border posts on the island
of Ireland to prevent a return to the
violence of the past
because the current deal as it stands
basically moves the EU UK border from
Ireland and into the Irish sea and that
means there has to be checks when goods
come from Great Britain over to Northern
Ireland that causes a headache for
businesses means a lot of paperwork and
also has led to shortages in some shops
there's also concern among unionists
those are the communities in Northern
Ireland that are passionate about
Northern Ireland's place in the United
Kingdom they think the deal means that
Northern Ireland is being treated two
differently to the rest of the UK
because EU law still applies there and
European courts still have a role too
there's a lot of detail that needs going
through but basically paperwork and
checks will mainly be gotten rid of by a
new high-tech system of red and green
lanes that essentially uses data to
figure out which goods are staying in
Northern Ireland and don't need checks
and which goods are going on to the
European Union there'll also be Powers
returned to here in Westminster from
Brussels over tax over vat and over some
spending and then on the issue of EU law
there'll be much more of a role for the
devolved assembly in deciding what EU
laws apply in Northern Ireland and the
Prime Minister says the UK government
will even have a veto
not exactly the UK and the EU seem very
pleased Rishi sunak said today this was
about breaking down barriers and was a
new chapter in our relationship with the
EU Ursula of on the lion as well said
that this delivers on commitments to
Northern Ireland and praised a historic
moment but I think the dup and unionist
communities are likely to be more
concerned because Northern Ireland will
still be treated differently to the rest
of the United Kingdom and it's the dup
party in Belfast that Richard sunac
really needs the support of it is clear
that significant progress has been
secured across a number of areas whilst
also recognizing that the remain key
issues of concern conservative
brexiteers might also be more concerned
because while Richie sunac has got more
out of Brussels than his predecessors
there are still some hard to swallow
compromises here
British scene access MPS will get a vote
on this so if they object and vote it
down it may never get off the paper a I
think a lot depends on what the dup does
if they're happy that will probably
reassure quite a few Tories if everyone
approves of it then it's a case of
turning something that at the moment is
a legal text something on a piece of
paper into something that works in
reality that probably means changing
laws setting up new processes and
putting in place new systems to handle
the new regime for taking goods from
Great Britain into Northern Ireland
[Music]
providing the deal isn't held up or torn
apart by politics here it should when
it's fully implemented mean that
shortages in Northern Ireland are
reduced and it's a lot easier for
businesses dealing across the Irish sea
as for the devolved assembly and
government in Belfast that hasn't sat
for more than a year because the dup are
boycotting it in protest at the problems
they have with the brexit deal they're
happy with this new Arrangement and they
decide to go back into Power sharing
that will mean those vital Democratic
institutions get back up and running
once again
[Music]
brexit's definitely more done than it
ever has been but this isn't the end for
a start we don't know what the dup or
Tory MPS think and then there's the
question of implementing this all which
could throw up problems and even if we
get to the point where all of this is
put into action there could be spats
further down the line when the UK or the
assembly in Belfast objects to new laws
that the EU wants to implement on
Northern Ireland so this isn't the end
and these arguments aren't going
anywhere soon
foreign